PEOPLE AND THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES.
WITH ME NOW IS GLENN GREENWALD,
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "SECURING
DEMOCRACY" AND, GLEN, YOU SAID
SOMETHING RATHER EXTRAORDINARY
TO ME TO TUCKER LAST NIGHT.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE WAY
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND OTHER
POWERFUL POLITICIANS WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE IN CHARGE OF
DEMOCRATIC OVERSIGHT OF THE NSA
AND THEIR LIKE, ARE ACTUALLY
UNDER SURVEILLANCE BY THESE
AGENCIES THEMSELVES AND SO ARE
ACTUALLY SCARED OF THEM.
>> YEAH, THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON
SINCE THE END OF WORLD WAR II
NATIONAL SECURITY STATE WAS
CREATED ON PURPOSE TO BE OUTSIDE
OF THE REALM OF DEMOCRATIC
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE ARGUMENT WAS WE NEED TO DO
THIS DETER THREAT NO LONGERS
EXISTS SOVIET COMMUNISM.
EVEN THEN THEY WERE CONSTANTLY
INTERFERING IN DOMESTIC
POLITICS.
J. EDGAR HOOVER HAD DOSSIERS.
THEY WERE PETRIFIED OF HIM.
HE COULD DO WHATEVER HE WANT.
AFTER DWIGHT EISENHOWER LEFT
AFTER 8 YEARS NO LEFTIST HE
CHOSE ONE TOPIC TO WARN THE
COUNTRY ABOUT WHICH WAS HE
CALLED THE MILITARY INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX IT WAS GROWING SO
RAPIDLY IT WAS BECOMING MORE
POWERFUL EVEN THAN ELECTED
LEADERS AND THAT WAS BEFORE THE
VIETNAM WAR.
BEFORE 9/11 AND NOW BEFORE THE
HYSTERIA OVER JANUARY 6TH AND SO
YOU HAVE THESE AGENCIES, MARK,
THAT DO WHATEVER THEY WANT,
INCLUDING COLLECTING INFORMATION
ON THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO
ARE THE ONLY ONES WHO CAN
EXERCISE OVERSIGHT OF THEM.
SO YOU CAN SEE WHY THERE IS
REALLY NO OVERSIGHT AT ALL.
THEY DO WHATEVER THEY WANT AND
POSE SUCH A GRAVE THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
>> Mark: BUT WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE J. EDGAR
HOOVER DAYS.
IN FAIRNESS TO THOSE GUYS THEY
ACTUALLY HAD TO GET INTO
SOMEBODY'S APARTMENT AND STICK A
BUG IN THE WARDROBE.
IT'S THE COMBINATION NOW OF
TECHNOLOGY AGAIN, INSANE HUGE
NUMBER 5 MILLION PEOPLE WITH
SECURITY CLEARANCES ANY LOW
LEVEL BUREAUCRAT CAN BASICALLY
SWITCH ON HIS COMPUTER AND BE
INSIDE THE EMAILS OF WHOEVER HE
WANTS.
>> I THINK THAT'S A KEY POINT.
THE INTERNET, WHEN IT FIRST
EMERGED, THE IDEA WAS IT WAS
GOING TO BE THIS UNPRECEDENTED
TOOL OF HUMAN LIBERATION.
TAWAS GOING TO ENABLE US TO
COMMUNICATE WITHOUT CENTRALIZED
CORPORATE AND STATE POWER.
AND, IN FACT, THE OPPOSITE HAS
HAPPENED WHICH IT WHICH IS IT
HAS BEEN TURNED INTO THE
GREATEST TOOL OF COERCION AND
CONTROL EVER KNOWN IN HISTORY
BECAUSE THE NSA SECRETLY, WHICH
IS WHAT EDWARD SNOWDEN CAME
FORTH TO REVEAL TO HIS FELLOW
CITIZENS HAD DECIDED TO USE IT
TO SPY ON EVERYBODY.
AND IT REALLY HASN'T BEEN REINED
IN SINCE THEN.
SO YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT'S THE EASE WITH WHICH ALL OF
OUR ACTIVITY THAT NOW TAKE PLACE
DIGITALLY, ESPECIALLY AFTER THE
COVID PANDEMIC, CAN BE COLLECTED
AND STORED AND MONITORED AND
ANALYZED AND THEN WEAPONIZED
WITH VERY LITTLE SAFEGUARDS.
>> Mark: YEAH, BASICALLY THEY
START FROM THE PREMISE, WHICH IS
AN ORWELLIAN PREMISE THAT THEY
MONITOR EVERYONE.
IT'S UNIVERSAL.
100 PERCENT.
AND THEN THEY PICK AND CHOOSE
THE BITS THEY NEED.
WHY IS THE LEFT AT EASE WITH
THIS?
IS IT JUST BECAUSE THEY THINK
WELL IT WILL AFFLICT TUCKER
CARLSON AND OUR OTHER ENEMIES
AND THAT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ANY OF THE DARKER IMPLICATIONS
OF TOTAL CONTROL?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S BIZARRE.
I WORKED ON THIS ISSUE FOR 15,
20 YEARS.
IT USED TO BE A MORE OR LESS
LEFT WING VIEW THAT THE SECURITY
STATE AGENCY SHOULDN'T BE
TRUSTED IT WAS MORE THE RIGHT
WING AND CONSERVATIVES WHO KIND
OF VENERATED THESE AGENCIES IN
THE NAME OF FIGHTING COMMUNISM
AND TERRORISM.
IT WAS REALLY THROUGH THE TRUMP
YEARS WHERE EVERYTHING REVERSED
BECAUSE THE CIA AND THE FBI
BECAME ROGUE AGENCIES OF THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATING TO SUBVERT
AND UNDERMINE THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT TO WHOM THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE ANSWERING.
SO, LIBERALS, NOT NECESSARILY
THE LEFT, BUT LIBERALS VIEWED
THE FBI AND THE CIA AS THEIR
ALLIES AND CONSERVATIVES FINALLY
REALIZED IF WE ALLOW THESE
INSTITUTIONS TO OPERATE IN THE
DARK, THEY CAN UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY AND SO EVERYTHING IS
KIND OF REVERSED NOW WHERE IT'S
THE RIGHT THAT DISRUPTS ALL OF
THESE AGENCIES AND LIBERALS WHO
REVERE THEM.
>> Mark: WELL, WE HAVE GOT
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THAT FOR YOU,
GLENN.
STICK AROUND IF YOU DON'T MIND,
BECAUSE THIS NEXT STORY IS ONE
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
UNLIKE ALMOST THE ENTIRE
AMERICAN MEDIA.
JULIAN ASSANGE IS THE WIKILEAKS
FOUNDER.
HE IS AUSTRALIAN, SO HE IS THE
SUBJECT TO THE QUEEN.
SO HE OWES NO ALLEGIANCE TO THE
UNITED STATES WHATSOEVER.
AND IF THE BLOATED BUFFOONS OF
THE U.S. INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ARE TOO INCOMPETENT TO KEEP
THEIR OWN SECRETS, THAT'S HARDLY
HIS FAULT.
BUT HE EMBARRASSED THEM.
SO THEY HAVE SPENT THE LAST
DECADE TRYING TO GET HIM INTO
JAIL.
AFTER LOSING ON BEINGS TRADITION
A COUPLE MONTHS BACK IN THE
WESTMINSTER MAGISTRATE'S COURT.
THEY ARE NOW APPEALING BY
PROMISES THAT OH, DON'T WORRY,
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BANG HIM UP
IN THE SUPER MAX BUT, PLEASE,
PLEASE, PLEASE EXTRADITE HIM.
WE WILL HANDLE HIM WITH ALL THE
CARE AND ATTENTION WE GAVE TO
JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
JULIAN ASSANGE SON AND FATHER
JOIN US NOW FROM SYDNEY.
GABRIELLE, YOU ARE JULIAN
ASSANGE'S BROTHER.
YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT THIS
APPEAL, I TAKE IT ONCE HE GETS
TO THE UNITED STATES AND HE IS
UNDER THE CUSTODY OF THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF PRISONS, YOU ARE
ACTUALLY CONCERNED HE IS NOT
GOING TO MAKE IT OUT OF THERE
ALIVE, WHATEVER HAPPENS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S WHY THE EXTRADITION WAS
REJECTED BACK IN JANUARY.
NOW THE PROSECUTION HAS GIVEN
THESE ASSURANCES THAT JULIAN
WON'T BE HELD IN FLORENCE,
COLORADO, SUPER MAX PRISON.
HE WON'T BE HELD.
CAVEAT IN THAT IN THAT BASICALLY
THEY CAN CHANGE THEIR MIND AS
SOON AS JULIAN GETS INTO THE
U.S.
IT'S UP TO THE CIA, THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CIA BASICALLY TO SAY
WHETHER JULIAN ENDS UP SANDS OR
WHICH PRISON HE ENDS UP IN.
THERE IS REALLY NO ASSURANCE AT
ALL IN HIS APPEAL.
IT'S JUST A WAY TO KEEP THIS
COURT PROCEEDING GOING AND KEEP
JULIAN IN A MAXIMUM SECURITY
PRISON IN LONDON WHERE HE HAS
BEEN NOW THIRD YEAR IN PRISON
THERE.
>> Mark: YEAH, AS YOU SAY, AS WE
ALL SAY, THE PROCESS IS THE
PUNISHMENT HERE.
HE HAS LOST A DECADE OF HIS LIFE
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS NEVER BEEN
CONVICTED.
OF ANYTHING ALREADY.
JOHN, WHAT DO YOU THINK THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IS DO THIS.
IN THE AUSTRALIAN GOVERNMENT
TRYING TO PUT AN AMERICAN IN
PRISON FOR LEAKING AUSTRALIAN
SECRETS.
AMERICANS WOULD BE ANSWER THOUGH
THAT WHY DO YOU THINK THE
U.S. -- ARRESTING AND JAILING
AND PURSUING 12 YEARS A
PUBLISHER AND JOURNALIST WHO
COMMENTED UPON THE NATIONAL
SECURITY INFORMATION.
SO, WON'T STOP ANY COMMENT BY
ANY JOURNALIST ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD INCLUDING THE UNITED
STATES ON NATIONAL SECURITY
MATTERS OF ANY MATTER THAT THE
CIA OR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
LIBERTY AND LIBERTY DEPENDS
SOLELY UPON FIRST AMENDMENT FREE
SPEECH.
IT'S COMPLETELY WRONG.
>> Mark: YEAH, OUGHT TO BE AN
AMERICAN ISSUE.
I MEAN, THEY DON'T IN AMERICA
LIKE YOU DO IN LONDON AND IN
SYDNEY WHERE THERE ARE
RESTRICTIONS ON THESE THINGS.
IN THEORY, IT OUGHT TO BE A
FREER CLIMATE HERE.
BUT, GABRIELLE, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU READ THE INDICTMENT, IT'S A
REALLY WEAK CASE THEY HAVE GOT
AGAINST YOUR BROTHER.
AND IT'S A PATHETICALLY WEAK
CASE AGAINST THE FOREIGN
NATIONAL THAT YOU ARE TRYING TO
GET EXTRA DIED.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT WHICHEVER
JUDGE IN LONDON THIS LANDS UP IN
FRONT OF WILL ACTUALLY STICK
WITH THE DECISION OF THE
WESTMINSTER COURT IN JANUARY AND
REJECT THIS FROM THE AMERICANS.
>> I THINK SO.
IN THE CASE IT JUST KEEPS
GETTING WEAKER AND WEAKER.
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO,
ONE OF THE KEY WITNESSES IN THE
PROSECUTION'S CASE RECANTED A
LOT OF THEIR ACCUSATIONS AGAINST
JULIAN, ICELANDIC MAN, HE
RECANTED HIS ACCUSATIONS THAT
FORMED PART OF THE JUDGMENT FROM
JANUARY 4TH.
SO, THIS ONE SECTION OF THE CASE
COMMIT COMPUTER INTRUSION.
UNDER PINS THE WHOLE CASE
TOTALLY UNRAVELING NOW.
SO THE CASE IS GETTING WEAKER
AND WEAKER DAY BY DAY.
SO, YOU KNOW, I EXPECT IN THE
NEXT HEARING WE WILL JUST HEAR
MORE ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
LENGTHS THAT THE DOJ HAS GONE TO
TO TRY AND, YOU KNOW, GAME THE
ESPIONAGE ACT AND U.S. LAWS TO
GO AFTER JULIAN.
SO, I THINK EVENTUALLY, THIS
WILL HAVE TO BE DROPPED.
>> Mark: WELL, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US FROM SYDNEY, JOHN AND
GABRIELLE.
I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED THAT,
THIS ICELANDIC WITNESS WHO HAS
SINCE RECANTED BECAUSE I ONLY
READ ABOUT THAT IN THE ICELANDIC
PRESS.
I DON'T REMEMBER READING ABOUT
IT IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES" OR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
SO LET'S GO BACK TO GLENN
GREENWALD, GLEN, YOU THINK THIS
SHOULD BE A GREAT FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS STORY FOR THE AMERICAN
NEWSPAPERS AND, YET, IT ONLY
SEEMS TO BE OF INTEREST TO
ICELANDERS AND AUSTRALIANS AND
OTHER PEOPLE.
>> AND TO FOX NEWS WHICH IS THE
ONLY PLACE THAT IS WILLING TO
COVER THIS.
AND THAT'S THE KEY ISSUE, MARK.
REMEMBER FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
THE U.S. MEDIA PROGRAM THAT BONE
GRANTLY PRANCED AROUND INTREPID
DEFENDERS MEAN TREATS FROM TRUMP
ABOUT WOLF BLITZER NOW YOU HAVE
A ALL CIVIL LIBERTY GROUPS POSE
A GREAT THREAT EXCEEDS AND
BECAUSE IT'S THE BIDEN JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT PURSUING IT THEY ARE
BASICALLY MOOT IF NOT
SUPPORTIVE.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL WATCH THEM
DOING THAT.
>> Mark: THESE ASSURANCES THEY
ARE GIVING TO THE ENGLISH COURT
ARE COMPLETELY WORTHLESS AS WE
KNOW IN EVERY CASE FROM JEFFREY
EPSTEIN TO BILL COSBY, THIS LAND
IS RIFE WITH PROSECUTORIAL
MISCONDUCT IN WHICH THEY
BASICALLY TEAR UP AGREEMENTS
THEY HAVE ENTERED INTO THAT
BASICALLY SUITS THEM.
>> AND, REMEMBER, THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HATE JULIAN ASSANGE
PROBABLY MORE THAN ANY SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL ON THE PLANET.
NOT ONLY DID HE REVEAL THEIR WAR
CRIMES UNDER OBAMA BUT MUCH
WORSE IN THEIR EYES DID HE
REPORTING IN THE 2016 ELECTION
THAT REFLECTED POORLY ON HILLARY
CLINTON.
THEY BLAMED JULIAN ASSANGE FOR
HELPING TRUMP GET ELECTED.
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
TREAT HIM HUMANELY OR JUSTLY OR
FAIRLY IF THEY GET THEIR HANDS
ON HIM?
>> Mark: NO, I DO NOT THINK SO.
AND I TELL YOU THIS, IF I WERE
THE RELEVANT CABINET MINISTER IN
LONDON, WHATEVER THE JUDGE SAYS,
I WOULD NOT EXTRADITE THIS GUY
TO THE UNITED STATES, I DON'T
LIKE THE WAY THEY ARE
TREATING -- I DON'T LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED TO JEFFREY EPSTEIN,
THEY CAN'T KEEP THE MOST
VALUABLE PRISONER IN AMERICA
ALIVE.
THE BUREAU OF PRISONS IS EITHER
IS EITHER INCOMPETENT OR EVIL.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE TRANSFERRING
THIS GUY INTO ITS TENDER CARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
ON THIS GLENN GREENWALD AND FOR
STICKING AROUND.
>> GREAT TO TALK TO YOU, MARK.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Mark: THANK YOU.
AND GLENN IS WORTH READING ON